[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
reportages et d'expertise sur Public
Sénat 90 minutes pour donner du sens à
l'actualité vous proposez les clés de
compréhension des crises que nous
traversons et voici le sommaire de ce 30
novembre le régime des Molas sans tête
dans une répression meurtrière contre la
jeunesse iranienne la rébellion féminine
contre le voile et devenu une révolte
populaire peut-être une révolution la
République islamique peut-elle
s'effondrer on en débat dans une minute
et puis dans trois quarts d'heure gros
plan sur un homme un milliardaire Elon
Musk et ce chiffre 44 milliards de
dollars c'est ce qu'il a dû débourser
pour racheter le réseau social Twitter
depuis il a licencié la moitié des
salariés et réintégrer 62 000 comptes
bannis pour de multiples infractions
dont le plus célèbre celui de Donald
Trump le twitter d'Elon musk met-il en
danger nos démocraties réponse tout à
l'heure
mais d'abord cette conférence organisée
hier soir par la délégation des droits
des femmes au Sénat des iraniennes des
Iraniens exilés venus raconter la
répression Fabien rekker adrienpin et
Audrey Vittaz étaient sur place
ma table gorbani poétesse et écrivait
iranienne brandit une photo d'elle
c'est parce que je n'ai jamais accepté
le voile obligatoire que les agents de
la République islamique ont frappés
l'image date de 2009 mais les méthodes
sont restées les mêmes ma table gorbani
s'est depuis exilée en France où elle
alerte sur le sort des Iraniens et
surtout des iraniennes depuis que des
manifestations soulève le pays après la
mort en détention de Macha Amini elle
subissent une répression féroce
c'est pas le courage ni la force de vous
dire ce qu'ils font aux femmes dans les
prisons de la République islamique ni
comment il les viole
imaginez le pierre
on a besoin de soutien de la
gouvernement française parce que les
gens en Iran nous veulent pas du tout le
régime République islamique au-delà du
message de soutien adressé aux femmes en
Iran les sénateurs en appellent à la
communauté internationale pour installer
un rapport de force avec le régime des
mots là il faut évidemment intensifier
les sanctions intensifier toutes les
sanctions non pas sur le peuple iranien
mais sur ces bourreaux les premières
mesures ont déjà été prises elles
doivent être renforcées au plan national
au plan international mais aussi au plan
européen pour geler les avoir des
responsables impliqués dans la
répression le Sénat travaille à une
proposition de résolution pour exiger
des sanctions une initiative qui devrait
être
et qui pourtant ne fait pas l'unanimité
mais vous savez bien que ça sert à rien
il faut vraiment
il va convaincre les pays
c'est à dire
qui l'Arabie saoudite le Qatar que
l'Iran démocratique c'est une chance
parce qu'on peut très bien imaginer que
les pays autour n'ont aucun intérêt à
avoir un Iron démocratique les sénateurs
exigent aussi l'exclusion de l'Iran de
la commission des Nations Unies sur la
condition des femmes depuis le début des
manifestations au moins 448 personnes
auraient été tuées selon une ONG
iranienne basée en Norvège
pour le 1er débat de ce sens public
j'accueille Marie Mercier bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sénatrice salaire de
Saône-et-Loire vous avez assisté à cette
conférence hier soir ici au Sénat
azalekian bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
professeur de sociologie spécialiste de
l'Iran professeur Université Paris Cité
et auteur de ce livre femme et pouvoir
en Islam aux éditions Michalon Farid
Vahid bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue à vous
directeur de l'observatoire de l'Afrique
du Nord et du Moyen-Orient à la
Fondation Jean Jaurès spécialiste de
l'Iran et Mathieu croissanto
éditorialise politique bonsoir bonsoir
et bienvenue Mathieu Marie Mercier un
mot de ce colloque pour commencer hier
soir au Sénat pourquoi faut-il marquer
ce soutien aux manifestants iraniens
je crois que nous devons réellement
marquer la solidarité du Sénat pour
rendre hommage à cette victime à Macha
mais aussi rendre hommage au courage des
femmes iraniennes qui sont sur place
mais aussi aux hommes nous avions au
Sénat le 5 octobre
participa à un débat sur les droits des
femmes et les droits de l'homme en Iran
chacun s'était exprimé donc évidemment
nos moyens peuvent paraître petits
insuffisant mais je crois qu'on ne peut
pas rester à côté c'est pas un
soubresaut de l'histoire ce qui se passe
en Iran on peut pas regarder ça de loin
et même si finalement on est un tout
petit peu démuni on est là quand même
et aux médias indépendants et très
difficiles en Iran mais celles et ceux
qui qui manifestent est-ce qu'ils
entendent l'écho de ce soutien
international qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce
qui revient à leurs oreilles en quelque
sorte tout à fait parce que quelques
heures par jour internet remarche d'une
part d'autre part il y a des télévisions
par satellite que beaucoup d'Iraniens
iranienne captent en Iran et donc de ce
fait il est elles sont au courant de
soutien donc par exemple de sénateurs et
sénatrices en France éventuellement et
d'autres d'ailleurs pour leurs
mouvements et c'est la raison pour
laquelle même si a priori ça peut être
ça peut paraître comme symbolique mais
quand même pour les encourager à
continuer dans leur lutte et dans leur
combat et dire que la communauté
internationale ou en tout cas les
démocraties soutiennent ce sourceau des
Iraniens iraniennes pour la démocratie
contre l'islam politique et pour la
liberté de choix c'est vraiment vraiment
important à cela s'ajoute le fait qu'on
attend quand même une résolution du
Sénat
Farid va comment la jeunesse iranienne
elle est très connectée alors on vient
de l'évoquer un petit peu comment
comment elle réussit à s'organiser parce
que c'est aussi ça comment on organise
des manifestations depuis deux mois et
demi depuis que la répression a commencé
c'est une très bonne question il y a
deux questions dans votre question
d'abord sur l'accès Internet pour savoir
les Iraniens donc on dit avec ça ça date
pas de deux mois donc un temps tu as
toujours été très limité on a tout ce
qu'on dit avec ça avec eux avec ça donc
il y a des solutions alternatives ça
avec des VPN avec différentes solutions
quand elle est comme ça va être interdit
ou migré sur Instagram donc quand un
réseau interdit il trouve quand même un
nouveau réseau en Iran c'est surtout
Twitter et Instagram et même quand
internet a fortement limité avec les VPN
ils vont réussir quand même avoir accès
après qu'on le régime peut couper
complètement Internet et peuvent le
faire pendant quelques heures dans
certains quartiers dans certaines
régions vous pouvez tout simplement pas
avoir accès Internet parfois ça peut
être difficile pour la diaspora de
rentrer en contact avec les Iraniens à
l'intérieur mais bon globalement ils
arrêtent quand même à envoyer les images
mais il faut savoir aussi les images
pour moi c'est pas tout ce qui se passe
en néant parce que beaucoup dire un lien
quand ils vont sortir pour aller
manifester ils vont pas prendre leur
téléphone parce que c'est dangereux ça
peut être risqué donc voilà c'est pour
ça aussi que c'est important de
rediffuser ces images parce que les
personnes prennent quand même beaucoup
de risques à enregistrer ces images pour
nous les envoyer j'aurais rejoins dans
le professeur c'est peut-être symbolique
mais c'est quand même un symbole très
important le soutien de l'Assemblée
nationale du Sénat ça a beaucoup circulé
sur les réseaux sociaux en Iran parce
que ça montre le courage c'est aussi une
guerre de narratif la Rapée il a dit non
mais de toute façon
on dit non mais de toute façon ce qui
compte pour la France c'est le gaz et le
pétrole donc ne pensait pas qui donc
faut quand même voilà faut donner les le
bon message aux Iraniens en leur
montrant notre soutien et alors sur
l'organisation des des des
manifestations
ça c'est compliqué en ce moment c'est
peut-être pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on a pas
des manifestations entre autres avec 3
millions de personnes dans les rues de
terrain comme ça tel qu'un 2009 bon à
l'époque parce qu'il y avait un
leadership un peu plus clair avec des
une organisation plus structurée pour
savoir la République question qui a tout
fait pour ça aussi il y a pas de partie
politique on ira à proprement parler il
n'y a pas de syndicat et c'est vrai que
l'organisation des manifestations
aujourd'hui est un peu difficile donc on
a 200 personnes dans un quartier de 100
personnes dans l'autre quartier donc ça
c'est un challenge et une question à
laquelle les manifestants doivent
trouver des solutions dans les
prochaines semaines prochaines mois
alors vous parliez de ces images qui
nous parviennent je vous propose deux
séquences pour pour visualiser bien
comprendre de ce qui se passe en ce
moment en Iran la violence des
manifestations de la répression sur
toutes ces manifestations évidemment
d'abord à Zaïda nous on est dans la
capitale de la province du système
Balouchistan sud-ouest du pays on est
près de la frontière iranienne c'était
le 26 novembre samedi dernier regardez
[Musique]
ce qui fera évidemment c'est ce tir en
fin de séquence autre vidéo publiait le
22 novembre alors là elle est tournée du
côté des forces de sécurité on est au
Kurdistan iranien à javannes
[Musique]
voilà l'objectif de cette séquence on
les voit ils vont aller jusqu'à détruire
voilà une une barricade beaucoup de
coups de feu de nombreux là j'ai une
question je sais pas si c'est facile de
répondre à zaequin de mes la répression
est-ce qu'elle est croissante ou est-ce
que finalement ça a été comme ça dès les
premiers jours
écoutez la répression la plus féroce je
dirais se passe au Kurdistan iranien et
au Baluchi en particulier vous avez
parlé de zaïdan le chef-lieu mais
également à Roche également à d'autres
villes de Baluchistan ou les gens
sortent en masse pas des centaines des
milliers et pareil au Kurdistan dans
différentes villes Kurdes et donc c'est
là que on a vu vraiment une répression
absolument atroce des manifestants selon
les organisations des droits humains
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
451 personnes ont été tuées dont 60
forces de coercition et les autres si
vous regardez c'est la plupart c'est les
personnes tuées au Kurdistan et au
baloutissants et puis d'autres disons
dans d'autres villes iraniennes
d'ailleurs ça contient 448 morts qui
s'affichent mais il est évolutif
évidemment est difficile à établir
encore hier soir
il y a eu aussi de nombreux tués parce
que alors le timely le football national
enfin l'équipe nationale a perdu à Qatar
1-0 aux États-Unis et les États-Unis et
les Iraniens étaient très contentes ils
étaient dans la rue et donc il y en a
qui se sont fait aussi tirer dessus par
les forces coercition
il y a plus de répression et plus de
manifestants au Kurdistan et au
Baluchistan iranien pour les raisons
régionales aussi parce que ils sont
davantage organisés alors on va
l'utilisant il y a Molana Abdul Hamid
qui est leur chef religieux et qui a une
autorité une personne modérée mais une
autorité dans l'autorité est acceptée
par tout le monde donc quand il appelle
par exemple soit descendre dans la rue
soit aller à la à la mosquée pour prier
en guise de contestation bah les gens le
suivent et pareil au Kurdistan parce que
les partis politiques sont parmi les
parties les plus anciens mais en même
temps qui sont
qui ont cette capacité
organisationnelles ce qui n'est pas le
cas dans des villes disons
où les gens descendent dans la rue mais
de façon vraiment spontanée sporadique
et comme ça a été dit dans ça se passe
au niveau des quartiers maintenant
contrairement au tout début où on a vu
des milliers de gens qui sont descendus
dans la rue bah on sait que il tire pour
tuer il tire aussi sur les enfants 64
enfants ont été tués aussi donc des
petites filles de 4 ans des petits
garçons de 9 ans donc c'est un régime
qui tire pour tuer pour massacrer et
pour essayer d'arrêter la mobilisation
Marie merci ça fait partie des
témoignages qui ont été entendus hier
soir au Sénat qu'est-ce qui vous a
frappé qu'est-ce qui vous a ému lors de
cette conférence tout c'était
effectivement extrêmement émouvant mais
moins de 18 ans c'est vrai ce sont des
enfants donc on a vu défiler leurs
photos on a vu des filmer leur âge et
définit les conditions dans lesquelles
ils avaient été tués donc ça nous
rendait les choses réelles et palpables
nous étions là dans cette émission
certains vraiment pleuré la princesse
Nour qui était là avec sa grand-mère
les larmes coulaient c'était une infinie
tristesse devant un gâchis terrible
devant ce régime qui tue l'amour et la
joie il disait c'est un régime de
terreur on avait ça sous les yeux et on
se sentait terriblement impliqué et
terriblement presque inutile
l'un des témoignages écoutaient un
extrait tout à l'heure c'est celui de
s'épiler c'est une exilée qui a connu
alors quand elle était plus jeune elle a
connu les jaunes du régime la première
fois elle n'avait que trois ans on
l'écoute
petit bateau un enfant de 10 ans vivant
Alizée phrase qui aujourd'hui est
devenue la nouvelle formule de la
Révolution
créatif et très joyeux il y a quelques
jours les agents terroristes des
Gardiens de la Révolution ont tiré en
salle sur la famille de Kyon dans la rue
grièvement blessé et le lendemain sa
mère a été torturée atrocement pour la
forcer à nier publiquement la réalité de
ce meurtre à la télévision nationale du
régime voilà c'est le petit garçon de 9
ans dont vous parliez tout à l'heure et
la photo dont vous parliez la voici ce
petit bonhomme au nom du dieu
arc-en-ciel c'est la est-ce que cette
phrase farine Vaï peut devenir un
nouveau cri de ralliement comment
comment vous recevez ce message d'un
enfant finalement parce qu'il y a il y a
des phrases qui qui portent la révolte
depuis deux mois et demi est-ce que une
phrase comme celle-là peut devenir un
cri du Ralliement oui sans doute c'est
extrêmement triste de voir un enfant de
7 ans assassiné par les forces du régime
avec une formule très touchante de Dieu
de l'arc-en-ciel forcément ça touche
beaucoup ça a été repris par beaucoup de
manifestants finalement c'est comme le
slogan femme vie liberté qui synthétise
parfaitement l'idée de ce moment
révolution donc oui bien sûr les
formules comptes et aujourd'hui comme ça
a été dit c'est épouvantable de voir
l'image de ces jeunes de ses enfants qui
sont qui sont assassinés parce qu'ils
veulent vivre libre parce que finalement
toutes les questions de liberté vous
l'avez dit de jouer aussi enfin ville
liberté vie parce qu'on ira c'est
presque interdit de vivre en tout cas de
manière joyeuse donc oui c'est une
formule extrêmement touchante où on a pu
voir sur les réseaux ça a beaucoup
circulé la société iranienne si on
essaye de de dézoomer un peu elle est
très jeune et c'est quoi la la pyramide
des âges en quelque sorte
je pense que Madame piano pourrait
répondre mieux que moi mais
c'est une société qui était très jeune
qui est de moins en moins de femmes ils
font de moins en moins d'enfants donc
c'est une société qui est devenue quand
même très moderne je pense les ma
génération en Iran faire entre 1 ou 2
enfants maximum mais ça reste quand même
on a quand même toujours beaucoup de je
n'en ai rien sur une population de 85
millions d'habitants donc on est sur une
société jeune et qu'il est de moins en
moins 70% de la population iranienne à
moins de 40 ans donc effectivement c'est
une population relativement jeune
relative à la France mais pas à
l'Algérie ou l'Arabie etc il faut quand
même situer les rendre dans son contexte
régional mais c'est une population
relativement jeune qui ce qui a du mal à
se reproduire puisque le long moyen
d'enfants parfois aujourd'hui n'est que
de 1,6 c'est à moi qu'en France donc du
fait aussi de la crise économique mais
aussi parce que c'est une société
devenue moderne et que les jeunes femmes
qui sont en âge féconde refuse d'avoir
beaucoup d'enfants pour pouvoir mieux
les éduquer voir elles-mêmes mis au
vivre elle-même voilà donc c'est une
société moderne et en face vous avez des
institutions comme j'ai expliqué hier
soir des institutions moyenâgeuses des
hommes au pouvoir qui sont absolument
répressives qu'on peut envoyer aussi et
donc ça a créé ça fait des années que
des tensions existent ce qu'il faut
souligner c'est que c'est 70% ils n'ont
connu que le régime islamique et donc ce
sont des gens qui ont grandi et vécu et
pour avoir été en Iran c'est vrai que la
population est et d'une certaine façon
schizophrène avec des institutions et un
mode de vie extrêmement rigoriste imposé
par le régime démola et en même temps
des images qui viennent de l'étranger
des références culturelles aujourd'hui
des habitudes de vie dans la sphère
privée qui sont complètement modernes
donc on a cette vie publique très
régentée cette vie privée beaucoup plus
libre et donc ça crée aussi une une
forme de tension au sein de chaque
personne de chaque iranien de chaque
iranienne alors combien de combien de
morts combien de personnes arrêtées
aussi je vous propose un premier élément
avec cette réaction du haut-commissaire
au droit de l'homme de l'ONU volcarthurk
flambouret d'après ce que nous avons pu
constater environ 14000 personnes y
compris des enfants ont été arrêtés dans
le cadre des manifestations c'est un
chiffre ahurissant
de de 14000 personnes et puis alors ça a
pu nous surprendre il y a aussi ce
chiffre du pouvoir iranien qui a reconnu
alors là je parle des des personnes
décédées car aucune ou pour la première
fois plus de 300 morts depuis le début
de la contestation on a vu que c'était
certainement en dessous de la réalité le
l'ONG Iran Newman Wright donné on a déjà
vu ce chiffre le bilan de 448 morts et
il est en train d'augmenter Farid Vaide
pourquoi je me suis posé cette question
pourquoi le régime iranien maintenant
reconnaît plusieurs centaines de morts
c'est une très bonne question c'est pour
donner l'image à leur partisan je pense
pour donner cette image qui contrôle les
choses pour dire non mais nous sommes
honnêtes et ils l'ont fait après l'avion
ukrainien après trois jours de ils ont
nié l'histoire pendant trois jours après
ils ont dit non oui effectivement
c'était un missile des gardes qui avait
abattu cette année je pense aujourd'hui
la stratégie c'est donner le sentiment
en partisans parce que quand même dire
ils existent ils sont très très peu et
ils sont de moins en moins nombreux et
s'il soutiennent toujours le régime pour
la plupart d'entre eux c'est pour les
intérêts économiques liés aux intérêts
du régime et peut-être quand même
quelques un petit pourcentages de
fanatiques donc il faut savoir aussi qui
se sentent très fragile et leur
partisans faut pas avoir le sentiment
qu'ils n'ont jamais peur ils se sentent
profondément fragiles et le gardien en
question le général qui a donné ces
chiffres moi mon analyse c'est il essaye
de donner le sentiment à ces troupes
qu'on contrôle la situation
effectivement il y a évidemment j'ai
écouté son discours en disant
malheureux et donner le sentiment que
bon on va contrôler on va aller en avant
sauf que ça ne se passera pas de cette
manière parce que la population de toute
façon ne fait plus confiance absolument
pas confiance aux propos des
responsables du régime et donc l'impasse
est réel
azalika est-ce que est-ce que c'est la
pire réaction fait un peu d'histoire
est-ce que c'est la pire répression qui
est connue l'Iran depuis 79 depuis la
Révolution islamique écoutez pire
répression de la population je dirais
ordinaire oui mais il faut pas oublier
que en 1988
de l'espace de quelques jours
4000 prisonniers politiques attendaient
leur libération ont été exécutées et à
l'époque le président actuel raïsme sera
ici était parmi enfin membre de ce
comité qui a ordonné l'exécution
sommaire de 4000 prisonniers politiques
avant ces 4000 il y en avait des
milliers d'autres qui avaient déjà été
exécutés toutes les familles iraniennes
connaissent des personnes exécutées soit
de leur famille soit des voisins soit
des amis c'est à dire des gens de mon
âge j'en connais beaucoup de mes amis
qui par exemple en péril en prison pour
avoir juste
distribuer un tract par exemple vendu un
journal de telle force politique de
l'époque donc c'est un régime
sanguinaire mais c'était des opposants
politiques à l'époque qui était surtout
exécuté aujourd'hui on tire même sur des
enfants qui sont dans la rue c'est c'est
pourquoi parce que à l'époque on est
pendant la guerre Iran Irak ils ont
réussi de rassembler beaucoup d'Iraniens
autour de
défense des territoires envahis etc et
donc peu de gens soutenaient les
prisonniers politiques alors
qu'aujourd'hui c'est exactement le
contraire qui se passe et ce régime est
très fragile très délégitimé ils ont
peur de tomber et donc pour ce
cramponner au pouvoir et se maintenir au
pouvoir il tous mais il tire mais il
tire sur tout le monde donc vous voyez
de ces deux types de répressions
différentes mais ce régime a toujours
été répressif face à ces violences
Matthieu comment la classe politique
française réagit cette révolte iranienne
l'événement dont on a parlé hier au
Sénat mais je vous donne comme comme
première réponse regardez une image
c'était lundi dernier à l'Assemblée
nationale les députés en fait ont adopté
à l'unanimité
149 exprimés 149 majorité 75 pour 149
contre 0 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
à l'unanimité bravo voilà il s'agissait
d'une résolution de soutien au peuple
iranien avec un texte présenté par
Adrien gomique et le député renaissance
de Seine-et-Marne dont la famille une
partie de la famille hétérogène d'Iran
ce sont les cheveux au vent la liberté
chevillée au corps et l'espoir en
étendard que les femmes iraniennes
rejoindent par les hommes se battent
courageusement pour leurs doigts à
lancer le député avant de se lancer
évidemment dans une critique en règle du
régime démola la résolution elle a été
adoptée par les députés enfin qui a été
adoptés par les députés et condamne avec
la plus grande fermeté la répression
brutale et généralisée à l'égard des
manifestants non violents elle dénonce
l'usage de la torture elle affirme son
soutien au peuple iranien en outre le
texte de mon dossier de la libération
immédiate des prisonniers français tout
ça ce sont des mots des mots importants
et les symboles ça compte en politique
mais certains demandaient aussi des
gestes un peu un peu plus forts alors on
a vu qu'il y avait une unanimité c'est
un bel exemple une période où
l'assemblée brille plutôt par ses
divisions c'est vrai parce que 149
présents 149 voix oui on n'a pas vu ça
beaucoup l'assemblée depuis 6 mois mais
derrière cette unanimité il y a eu
quelques critiques qui ont été émises
par plusieurs députés qui ont été
certains que le texte n'aille pas assez
loin alors mais hier Habib par exemple
des républicains qui lui est vraiment
très très critique sur le nucléaire
iranien sur
le rôle que j'oubliaison
André Chassaigne aussi a regretté que
qu'on élu de la partie programme
nucléaire iranien angélique Franck pour
le rassemblement national elle
critiquait le fait que la résolution
propose une action à l'échelle de
l'Union européenne parce qu'elle
considère elle que l'institution Union
européenne fait la promotion du voile on
essaierait que vous souvenez de
certaines campagnes qu'on avait vu dites
inclusive de l'Union européenne sur le
port du voile or la question du voile
des iraniennes justement à poser
quelques problèmes à gauche notamment et
à qui alors plusieurs élus de la nups en
fait ont été pris depuis le début de
cette révolte iranienne dans leur
contradiction en fait dès le
déclenchement je parle je pense à
Sandrine Rousseau par exemple pour les
écologistes à Daniel obono ou encore
pour la France insoumise pour ne citer
que je disais qu'ils ont été mis devant
leur contradiction parce que comment
défendre le port du voile comme une
liberté ici en France et soutenir les
Iraniennes qui le brûle et le voit comme
un symbole d'oppression là-bas en Iran
certains d'entre eux ont même été sifflé
dans une manifestation et faute d'avoir
pu résoudre cette difficile équation il
faut le dire c'est impossible équation
beaucoup de ces élus se sont réfugiés
derrière des sophistes Argan qui se
battaient pour la liberté de le porter
ou non même si on n'a pas beaucoup vu de
femmes en Iran se battent pour la
liberté de porter le voile on a plutôt
vu le contraire évidemment c'est une
façon de masquer en fait que
c'est ses élus qui se battent contre
toutes les oppressions capitalisme
masculines racistes ont fait l'impasse
sur une oppression que l'oppression
religieuse
en plus islamiste en particulier et donc
du coup c'est une forme d'angle mort
pour pour l'insoumission je voudrais
revenir Marie merci sur la question
d'une résolution de soutien aux peuple
iranien effectivement ça a été adopté à
l'Assemblée nationale on en est où au
Sénat qu'est-ce qui peut se passer dans
les prochains jours effectivement hier
Adrien Gomy était là au Sénat donc il
nous a remis cette proposition de
résolution son soutien mouvement pour la
liberté du peuple iranien mais comme l'a
expliqué Bruno retaillod qui c'est lui
dirigé hier cette réunion en faveur de
des chrétiens d'Orient et du peuple
iranien aimeraient aller plus loin dans
les sanctions donc pour le moment c'est
pas encore tout à fait écrit c'est vrai
qu'il faut aller
le plus loin possible pour montrer
combien nous sommes déterminés à aider
les Iraniens les manifestants iraniens à
Paris en tout cas eux demandent par
exemple des gestes symboliques très
forts comme la fermeture de l'ambassade
en France qui refuse les autorités
françaises ils disent qu'il faut
maintenir le fil du dialogue entre Paris
était en
est-ce que c'est une révolte contre le
symbole religieux qui est le vol
islamique puisqu'on évoquait cette
question à la effectivement c'est pas un
symbole religieux c'est le symbole de
l'islam politique il faut pas oublier
que des le début de la révolution de 79
c'est à dire dès l'installation du
régime le port du voile est devenu
obligatoire en Iran et donc en tant que
symbole de l'idéologie islamiste et donc
c'est ça que les jeunes femmes que nous
étions que moi j'étais à l'époque aussi
nous avons rejeté elle nous sommes
descendus dans la rue un mois après la
victoire de la révolution lorsque le
voile est devenu obligatoire pour dire
non et donc ça ça fait 43 ans que les
Iraniennes disent non à l'obligation du
dévoile c'est à dire non au symbole
idéologique de l'islam politique et ce
que les femmes jeunes femmes aujourd'hui
brûlent c'est l'islam politique qui est
brûlé c'est pas l'islam il faut pas
quand même mélanger des choses il faut
contextualiser l'Iran n'est pas la
France d'une part d'autre part ce qui
est brûlé en Iran c'est le voile
imposait le symbole de l'islam politique
d'une part et ce color revendique les
femmes iraniennes c'est la liberté de
choix de le porter ou non on le voit
souvent dans les manifestants un
manifestations il y a beaucoup de femmes
qui portent elles-mêmes le voile qui
soutiennent les femmes qui sont en train
de brûler leur voile donc il y a aussi
la réalité l'Iran comme n'importe quel
autre société est une société multiple
et il faut permettre à cette société
multiple d'exister diversifié et
multiples et que tout le monde doit
avoir la liberté de vivre comme il est
elle le souhaite c'est ça la
revendication de mes compatriotes
actuellement qui se et voilà ça fait 43
ans que elle les autres aussi se sont
battus pour cette liberté là maintenant
je suis désolé il faut pas
instrumentaliser les luttes des
iraniennes ce que fait l'extrême droite
en France pour
excusez-moi l'expression mais pour taper
sur les musulmans musulmanes en France
moi ce que je dis c'est il faut se
battre contre l'islamisme
en Iran en France et ailleurs mais pas
contre l'islam ni contre les femmes qui
dans la rue porte le voile je parle pas
de voile intégrale là c'est encore autre
chose mais parce qu'on voit leur visage
on voit de qu'il s'agit etc et là on a
besoin d'un bien vous comprendre ça veut
dire qu'en France c'est pas forcément un
symbole de l'islam politique non pas
parce que il y a beaucoup de femmes
musulmanes moi je travaille aussi sur le
Moyen-Orient pas seulement sur l'Iran je
vois beaucoup de femmes par exemple en
Turquie qui sont contre elles doivent
qui se battent contre le le président
donc le président islamiste turc mais
qui porte leur voile quand même c'est
une tradition culturelle pour beaucoup
donc ils font ce dont on a besoin en
France Monsieur c'est vraiment un débat
sérieux avec des spécialistes de la
question et pas les partis politiques
qui s'en mêlent pour l'instrumentaliser
pour qu'on voit la la multiplicité de de
voile et la polysémie du voile qui est
porté ou ou voilà ou qui est rejeté
d'ailleurs hier au Sénat il y avait des
jeunes femmes qui portaient le voir et
qui portait le voile qui était là
jusqu'à la fin oui qui sont venus même
aux communes
sociétale plutôt qu'une révolte
politique ce qui se passe en Iran c'est
d'abord une révolution culturelle pour
libérer les corps de l'imposition
vestimentaire l'imposition idéologique
etc c'est une révolution politique parce
que tout logistique en Iran bien
évidemment vu que l'Islam a été
politisée donc quand on jette on rejette
le voile et ben forcément on est en
train de faire un acte politique et
surtout maintenant avec des slogans qui
vont avec il faut écouter les slogans
c'est contre le régime contrairement à
avant ou les gens revendiquaient la
réforme voilà ils se sont rendus compte
que le régime n'est plus réformable
moi-même moi-même je revendiquais la
réforme enfin je revendiquais j'étais
avec les Iraniens Iraniens qui votaient
par millions pour les réformistes afin
de d'introduire des changements
conséquents dans ce pays à travers la
réforme parce que la révolution on a vu
en 79 ce que ça a donné donc mais
malheureusement on se rend compte que ce
régime n'est pas réformable d'où cette
mobilisation que j'appelle une
révolution en devenir une révolution de
venir ça faisait partie des questions
que j'avais prévu de vous poser révolte
révolution est-ce que Farid Weid cette
révolte ou Révolution elle était
prévisible est-ce qu'on l'a on sent
compter cette révolte depuis plusieurs
mois peut-être même un peu plus d'un peu
plus d'une année je pense que tous les
Iraniens oui le santé déjà et pour des
raisons multiples faut comprendre le
contexte vous avez une crise économique
qui est lié à la corruption
systèmeatique du régime au sanctions et
là aussi il faut faire très attention
quand on parle des sanctions il faut
quand même faire attention de ne pas
cibler la population iranienne et de
cibler et le régime iranien donc c'est
comme une petite nuance à respecter et
aussi la corruption systématique c'est
un régime mafieux le régime iranien donc
imaginons même s'il y avait pas eu de
Trump et il y avait pas eu de sanctions
il y aurait ils sortent plus de PIB en
Iran mais est-ce que ça aurait une
fenêtre vraiment servir les Iraniens ça
c'est une question ouverte le et un
débat entre les opposants donc il y a la
dimension économique la dimension
économique la dimension politique
l'origine n'a aucune légitimité
politique depuis longtemps mais de plus
en plus pourquoi parce que avant les
Iraniens comme ça a été dit avait quand
même un espoir dans la réforme donc
effectivement retaming ou en ligne avait
été avec 20 22 23 millions de personnes
qui avaient voté pour eux en 2009 la
révolte du Mouvement Vert parce que
syriens avait massivement participé à
une élection il voulait me renseigne
l'élection était truqué donc il y a eu
le mouvement de protestation aujourd'hui
il y a plus aucune légitimité politique
qui en avait pas il y a 2 ans non plus
mais alors aujourd'hui c'est une crise
majeure de légitimité politique parce
que les Iraniens ont compris qu'au sein
du régime il n'y a pas de solution il
n'y a pas d'alternative donc forcément
quand vous avez pas adapté un type au
sein du régime la salade alternative se
trouve en dehors du régime donc anti
régime donc vous avez crise économique
politique mais aussi sociétale les
Iraniens des hirondins n'inspire une vie
je peux utiliser le terme occidentalisé
mais en tout cas une ville libre avec un
style de vie moderne ce qui n'est pas
permis en Iran donc vous avez toutes ces
crises qui s'accumulent et là ça se
mette l'insomnie et c'est le couteau qui
a fait exploser tout ça et nous sommes
pas face à une révolte pour le coup je
pense qu'on peut vraiment s'en prendre
de risque parler d'un mouvement
révolutionnaire parce que les slogans
visent le régime le voile quand elle
brûle le voile elle brûle les seins
politiques du régime donc le régime en
entier nous sommes dans un mouvement
révolutionnaire est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'il y aura un changement de régime
dans deux semaines ou deux mois je suis
pas un prophète je peux pas le dire mais
c'est évident que ça sera une étape
importante dans ce changement qui
arrivera tôt ou tard en Iran alors on va
parler des sanctions internationales
tout de suite avec Alexandre poussa vous
pouvez nous rejoindre sur ce plateau
bonsoir Alexandre l'Union européenne
renforce au fil des semaines des
sanctions vis-à-vis de ce régime iranien
on va les détailler quels sont ces
sanctions et la stratégie européenne
c'est de cibler les personnalités du
régime iranien qui sont responsables de
cette répression une trentaine de
personnes sont visées par les sanctions
actuellement et notamment cet homme
armad vaidi le ministre de l'Intérieur
iranien qui accusait d'avoir commis de
graves violations des droits de l'homme
concrètement toutes ces personnalités du
régime et bien elles ont interdiction de
pénétrer sur le territoire européen elle
voit également leurs avoir en Europe
gelés à la chaîne publique iranienne
presse TV est également
cibler elle a diffusé des aveux forcés
de manifestants emprisonnés écoutez
Emmanuel Macron sur section sur ces
sanctions européennes la grande
difficulté vous savez dans ces cas là
c'est d'être sûr que les sanctions ont
une efficacité qu'elles ne pèsent pas
sur la population on y veille toujours
et d'être sûr que Vous sanctionnez les
bonnes personnes c'est-à-dire celles et
ceux qui sont au cœur du système et les
Gardiens de la Révolution font partie
exactement et donc on l'a fait on a
amélioré le pardon de ce terme mais le
ciblage la précision de ces sanctions et
dans le même temps moi je veille je veux
aussi essayer d'engager la région dans
comme on l'avait fait il y a un an avec
la conférence de Bagdad parce que on
doit pas simplement réagir je dirais de
notre côté on doit engager les pays
voisins aussi mettent cette pression
voilà Emmanuel Macron qui veut aller
plus loin dans la pression sur l'Iran et
qui n'exclut pas de placer les Gardiens
de la révolution sur la liste des
organisations terroristes alors ça c'est
pour les sanctions européennes ou alors
maintenant ce que fait l'ONU alors
beaucoup de discours de condamnation de
cette répression de la part de l'ONU et
sur le plan des actes il y a également
quelques avancées la semaine dernière le
Conseil des droits de l'homme de l'ONU a
voté une résolution pour créer une
mission d'enquête internationale sur la
répression iranienne alors quelques pays
étaient absolument opposés à cette
enquête un internationale notamment la
Chine mais une majorité de pays ont voté
en faveur de la résolution donc c'est
une réelle avancée mais concernant l'ONU
il y a un point qui ne passe pas du tout
c'est la présence de l'Iran dans la
Commission des droits des femmes des
Nations Unies écoutez la sénatrice
Annick billon qui demandait hier soir au
Sénat et bien que la France monte au
créneau sur ce sujet comment accepter
par exemple que l'Iran soit toujours
membre de la commission de l'ONU sur la
condition de la femme le Canada et les
États-Unis se sont déjà prononcés pour
une exclusion de l'Iran de cette
commission une hygiène qu'attendons-nous
et puis pour finir Alexandre il faut
rappeler les sanctions déjà prises
contre l'Iran pour l'empêcher de se
doter de l'arme nucléaire oui depuis le
retrait des États-Unis de l'accord sur
le nucléaire iranien et la violation de
cet accord parlant et bien Téhéran subit
de lourdes sanctions internationales un
embargo sur l'arme le pétrole des
restrictions dans le domaine financier
également dans le déplacement des hautes
unitaires du régime donc avant le début
de cette révolte et bien les sanctions
étaient déjà lourdes contre les rangs
merci beaucoup Alexandre pour ça Marie
merci Kets qui a été évoqué hier soir en
matière de de sanction jusqu'où jusqu'où
peut-on aller
le plus loin possible mais comme en
faisant vraiment attention effectivement
à la population pour ne pas nuire à la
population alors il y a des sanctions
probablement économiques des sanctions
de
tous ordres pour le moment moi je n'ai
pas encore la définition de ces de ces
sanctions là j'espère que dans la
résolution on pourra on pourra les
définir pour effectivement aller le plus
loin possible
vous disiez tout à l'heure attendre la
résolution du du Sénat on a commencé ce
débat en disant voilà l'écho de la
mobilisation internationale voilà se
faisait entendre en Iran ça vaut aussi
pour ce que vient de nous décrire
Alexandre poussat donc si le Sénat vote
une résolution ça sera entendu là-bas si
l'Europe va plus loin dans les sanctions
c'est attendu aussi à condition qu'elle
soit ciblées c'est ça le message
important à faire passer et 32 je suis
désolé mais 32 personnes ne suffit
absolument pas parce que si vous faites
par exemple le Canada
passionné a mis enfin à publier une
liste de 10000 personnes donc pourquoi
la personne qui sont dans dans
l'entourage du pouvoir d'un système
d'accord donc 30 personnes c'est
vraiment pas grand chose à cela s'ajoute
la demande comme moi-même je fais aussi
depuis de nombreuses nombreux nombreuses
semaines au moins c'est de aussi
sanctionner de façon ciblée les enfants
de 5000 enfants des personnes qui sont
au pouvoir vit à l'étranger en Europe
aux États-Unis au Canada et donc qui
vraiment
profit de la liberté de la des systèmes
démocratiques mais en même temps de la
manne pétrolière et c'est à dire
l'argent qui revient aux Iraniens au
peuple iraniens donc le gel des avoir
doit aussi s'imposer à aux enfants de
ces personnes là et pas seulement à 32
mais à des milliers d'entre eux et donc
là c'est quelque chose qui est tout à
fait faisable permettez-moi de dire que
il y a l'année dernière par exemple les
Iraniens lambda les Iraniens qui même
étaient une carte séjour en France ne
pouvait pas ouvrir un compte en banque
et c'est toujours le cas et les Iraniens
qui même habite ici et qui ont des
appartements ou une propriété ici mais
étant de nationalité iranienne ne
pouvait même pas utiliser leur compte
bancaire c'était interdit ça c'était des
gens ordinaires qui n'avaient pas grand
chose sur leur compte pourquoi on peut
pas faire ça avec les tournants de ce
régime et leurs enfants c'est facile à
faire il faut une volonté politique
madame c'est résolution vraiment doit
aussi refléter cette volonté politique
et ça prend du temps mais il faut le
faire et ça c'est un message sérieux on
peut pas prendre les gens de régime ici
en otage c'est une démocratie la France
mais on peut geler leurs savoirs
est-ce que parce que il y a des
sanctions depuis longtemps on le sait
notamment avec la question du programme
nucléaire mais est-ce que finalement ce
régime a pas appris à les contourner
quel est l'effet déjà c'est une très
bonne question faut faire attention aux
sanctions dans le sens où il ne faut pas
donner aussi le sentiment d'un qu'on est
juste en des actions symbolique pourquoi
je dis ça l'Iran est déjà le pays le
plus sanctionné du monde les sanctions
contre la Russie à côté des sanctions
contre l'iranes sont pas encore
grand-chose avec l'extracteur réalité du
droit américain l'Iran est en fait tout
sanctionné par le monde entier donc
c'est un pays complètement
économiquement isolé après vous avez
raison ils ont pu développer des
techniques pour contrôler les sanctions
mais effectivement ce qui est quand même
absurde c'est de voir que des étudiants
iraniens vont avoir du mal à ouvrir un
compte en France en raison des sanctions
américaines mais les enfants ont du
régime qui partage les valeurs de leurs
parents vont aller se marier à
Saint-Tropez c'est qu'elle a existent
donc on peut travailler sur ça en Iran
vous avez une oligarchie comme
l'oligarchie russe donc effectivement on
peut travailler pour bloquer la vie de
ces gens après il y a des actions
juridiques contre ceux qui sont dans la
répression et faut vraiment réfléchir à
toutes ces solutions le Quai d'Orsay le
ministère des armées mais juste un petit
point je pense le point aussi qui
complique
l'action des états des puissances
occidentales contre l'Iran faut le dire
c'est le dossier nucléaire indien
aujourd'hui c'est impossible de Jessie
n'en veulent pas ça serait un très
mauvais message envoyé aux Iraniens
d'aller signer un accord avec cette
personne là impliquée dans la répression
donc je pense aujourd'hui il faut aussi
envoyer clairement le message à la
République questionnique aussi en lien
qu'on a un plan B au DCP on va s'assurer
que l'Iran n'aura pas l'harmonie claire
parce que personne n'a envie que la
République islamique se doute de l'arme
nucléaire et qu'en même temps on va pas
négocier avec ceux qui sont en train de
vous tuer dans la rue alors je voudrais
terminer par un témoignage et une image
vous l'avez évoqué rapidement tout à
l'heure finalement le le rapport à
l'équipe nationale iranienne de football
et et son parcours dans la Coupe du
Monde au
Qatar qui est devenu un enjeu politique
écoutez d'abord donc un témoignage qu'on
dit Farid Bradley c'est une artiste
d'origine iranienne qui vit en
Angleterre avec d'autres femmes venus
d'Iran l'image et son témoignage est
fort elle refuse catégoriquement de
soutenir cette équipe de foot
les Iraniens qui soutiennent vraiment
leur équipe bien sûr voudront que l'Iran
gagne mais s'il gagne l'argent revient
au régime et le régime utilisera sans
aucun doute les images de joie comme
propagande ils sont très habiles pour
faire de la propagande beaucoup
d'anciens champions par exemple dans le
domaine du judo ont pris la parole ce
qui est très courageux de leur part ils
ont pris la parole en ligne et sur
Instagram pour dire qu'il ne faut pas
soutenir l'équipe car le régime va s'en
servir
symboliquement elle tournait le dos au
poste de télévision au moment de de
l'hymne qui est l'hymne du régime il
faut bien expliquer ce qui est ce qui
signifie et donc vous l'avez évoqué tout
à l'heure on va voir les images cette
cette vidéo juste après la défaite de
l'équipe de l'Iran face au États-Unis
des fêtes qui éliminaient l'Iran de la
Coupe du Monde bah voilà on est on est
avec un concert de klaxon normalement
c'est plutôt quand son équipe gagne
elle est évidemment surprenante on est
dans les rues de Téhéran
pourquoi peut-être vous pouvez nous
l'expliquer en quelques mots pourquoi
l'équipe nationale est devenue le
symbole du régime parce que au premier
match il ne chante pas l'hymne les
joueurs mais ils l'ont chanté au
deuxième et je crois un peu marmonner au
3e écoutez parce que avant d'aller au
Qatar ils sont allés voir le président
iranien Haïti où on serrait la main etc
donc ça a été très critiqué par beaucoup
beaucoup d'Iraniens ensuite
effectivement pour réparer ça ils ont
refusé de chanter l'hymne du régime
islamique qui n'est pas l'hymne national
et ensuite deuxième fois pour le ils
l'ont changé et ils l'ont chanté pardon
ils l'ont chanté et là ils sont devenus
à nouveau les cibles privilégiées des
opposants bien évidemment il y avait la
peur pardon nous interrompre que en cas
de victoire et de qualification de
l'Iran en 8e de finale ce soit
finalement récupéré par
le régime déjà pas utiliser récupérer
les images de c'était le match
contre l'Iran en Pays de Galles là où
l'Iran a gagné et donc les Iraniens de
l'Iran n'ont pas réagi mais les gens du
régime et les forces de coercition
étaient dans la rue pour danser et là
bien évidemment c'est très au détriment
de timely donc l'équipe nationale qui
est devenu aussi
associé ou identifier au régime et donc
rejeter par les Iraniens merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce à ce
débat avec Ken je rappelle le titre de
votre livre femme et pouvoir en Islam
livre publié aux éditions
Michalon le voici merci encore d'être
venu sur notre plateau